the world fell in love with my story
but it was a lie
[Applause]
Oscar De La Hoya was the most popular
fighter since Muhammad Ali
I've never told anybody
what really happened
at six years old out come the gloves I
started fighting kids
punched in the face my father told me be
tough you're gonna take us out of this
lifestyle it's a lot of pressure he said
he was going to be champion of the world
what are you laughing at this is my
dream
I'm gonna show you
before my mother passed away she told me
she wanted to go metal
I was on a mission to make history
I'm 24 making 20 million dollars a fight
there was nobody bigger I was hanging
out with beautiful women I felt like a
star everything Delaware touches has
turned to gold the golden left hook the
golden story but truth always comes out
and I knew it would come back to haunt
me
Money Changes Everything nothing he said
to me was the truth my dream became a
nightmare
all this anger
I have to free myself
won 11 World titles in six different
weight classes I want to be that hero I
could see myself fighting and I don't
even know why I'm fighting
who in the am I
[Music]